so jackie you say um one of your most
embarrassing moments involved
leftovers how oh good lord
well see my problem is i never met a
leftover i didn't like
and i went with a friend to this super
fancy restaurant called craigs in l.a
and as a person who is only newly fancy
i'd never heard of it
i looked terrible greasy bangs camo
t-shirt i walk up to this place there's
paparazzi everywhere i'm like okay
they're not looking for me
i go in jlo and a-rod are at one table
maroon 5 is at another table i'm like
where am i we finished the meal
but the waiter says like hey do you guys
want to take anything take your
leftovers to go
my friend says no so fast like my hair
blows back he's like absolutely not
we're good and i was like
oh i'll take his aunt and mine obviously
leftovers
and then we order dessert i take those
leftovers as well
it took the guy like 30 minutes to wrap
it up because i truly think i was the
first person
to ever take food to go from this very
fancy establishment
i leave the paparazzi catches me
for my first time taking all my
leftovers from craig's
not one of my proudest moments but i'll
tell you something their chicken parm is
just as good the next day
oh i love their chicken i've actually
i've only been there a couple times i
didn't know it was one of those hangs
either because that's not my thing
but i do their food is really good so i
see why you
look at home yeah i just had no idea
yeah yeah and it just seems wasteful
leaving great food like that yep i'm
still here just waiting for you to
subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever